hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and
i have a lot of dead skin
it's gotten a lot worse during lockdown because
normally i keep my skin quite exfoliated for pole
but dance studios are closed so i've just been
letting myself turn into a scaly snake
just sort of growing a cocoon around myself
so when i found out about these special
exfoliating mitts that make rolls of
skin come off i got pretty excited because i
knew i was in for a treat a disgusting treat
i was actually contacted by
a journalist at insider who
wanted to do a story about these exfoliating mitts
well we normally have 10 to 20 layers of
dead skin in our stratum corneum this is
the topmost level of our epidermis these cells
normally shed in a process called desquamation
but sometimes your skin needs a bit of a nudge
how well your skin desquamates depends
on a lot of factors like age hydration
the climate you're in your skin care routine
in general moisturized skin sheds more easily
if you have too much dead skin then it looks dry
and flaky and dull and it can also trap ingrown
hairs these mitts are sold as turkish bath mittens
but i think they're actually used by a lot of
cultures around the middle east and north africa
they're traditionally used after a steam bath when
the skin is really soft they're mostly advertised
for use on the body but some of them also say that
you can use them on your face the most famous one
is probably the baiden glove biden glove it is $72
it has rave reviews it calls itself the superior
exfoliating glove and the keywords on amazon
include dead skin highly recommend make sure
stretch marks dry skin worth every every penny
worth the money much dead so overall very
promising but right next to it on amazon i also
saw gloves that were only eight dollars each so
of course i had to buy them all and try them out
there are actually two types of the
cheaper gloves there's one that is
a lot rougher and one that is a lot softer and
the listings didn't really give an indication
about how rough or soft they were going to be
the mitts are made from rayon fiber they have a
weave that makes them a balance of rough and soft
so rough enough to scrub off skin but soft enough
that you don't destroy your skin they work a bit
like really fine grit sandpaper they mechanically
buff away dead skin cells so these are our three
contenders for great mitt i guess this is
the baiden mitten this is the expensive one
it comes in i guess relatively fancy cardboard
packaging it's like a sachet that's covered in
very direct marketing like shopping tv
style packaging it has like a little
money back guarantee seal in the corner it has
papyrus font is that how you say it i don't
know probably should have checked it also comes
with like the story of the mitten inside it and
like it's got you know actual marketing copy with
instructions in theory this is meant to last for
two years now with the other two mittens obviously
they don't come in anywhere near as interesting
packaging they came in like a sandwich bag but i
don't know i don't think i'd pay all that extra
money just for the cardboard packaging although
it is probably a nice read so that's your choice
with the texture the expensive baiden mitten it
has a fine sort of grit but it still feels rough
with this one it has the same fine fineness of
grit but it feels a lot smoother almost like
it's been worn down already and with the third
mitt it's a lot rougher and a lot coarser as well
so we'll see how these go in terms of results
after using them a bunch of times you can actually
really feel the difference between the fabric
the baiden glove feels a lot finer and thinner
these other two gloves are a bit stiffer they
don't feel like they're quite as nicely woven
i guess the baiden glove definitely feels like
it's higher quality so the instructions say to
try these right after a shower and to rub back and
forth and not in circles i tried out the baiden
glove versus the red glove on my shins the baiden
glove definitely gets the rolls off much faster
you can see there's a lot more rolls but the red
glove does pretty well as well the black glove is
a bit underwhelming compared to the other two you
can see there are some rolls but it takes a lot of
effort so with all the messing around with the
cameras i think my second shin dried out a bit
before i got to it so it might be a bit biased
so i tried again on my thighs but i did it with
the red and the black gloves first so i tried
the opposite order with the cheaper gloves first
with the black glove i got a tiny bit with
the red mitt i got some rolls and with the
baiden mitt i got some rolls as well so i think
the red mitt is capable of getting these rolls
maybe not as much as the baiden mitt
my skin was super super soft afterwards
now all of these mitts say you can use them on
your face but i'm really hesitant to use the
red one on my face because it feels so much
rougher than the other two the baiden mitt
apparently is fine for your face and i did end
up using it on one of my cheeks i did get some
small rolls off but i didn't press very hard
because i was pretty scared and my cheek felt
redder and hotter afterwards but it didn't really
sting any more than my other cheek when i put on
products afterwards so i don't know if i would
recommend using it on your face maybe if you don't
use any other exfoliating products if you don't
use any irritating ingredients then using this
maybe once a week on your face with very gentle
pressure is fine but i think for most of us people
who use a lot of irritating skin care products
it's probably not the best thing your barrier
is probably compromised enough already i also
looked at the weave of these under a microscope
so you can see that the baiden mitt does
have a different weave from the other two
and that might explain why it works a bit better i
also looked through the roll covered glove through
my microscope you can see that the rolls are
actually dead skin yes this is what it looks
like if you put your eyeball right up to it the
mitt is intact the rolls don't look like the
fibers in the mitt so it's very different from a
peeling gel where the rolls are bunched up product
now about the claims the beta myth does claim
to be like microdermabrasion and i think that
might be a bit much i really don't think this
is going to do as much as microdermabrasion
maybe if they had a study where they compared the
two head to head i'd be okay with that comparison
but as it stands i think it is pretty exaggerated
so it says there's an immediate improvement in
blackheads and large pores i think with black as
maybe you might dislodge them especially after the
steam from the shower but i don't think you'll
do that much blackheads are oxidized sebum and
cells inside your pores they're not really on the
surface this sort of exfoliation is very surface
level i think you would get much more benefit
if you use something like a chemical exfoliant
that can get deeper into the pores same with large
pores i don't think it's going to do very much
with firmness and wrinkles i think this does
increase the circulation which can make your
skin temporarily more firm it's not going to
do anything like stimulate collagen for example
though now with wrinkles i think exfoliation in
general does help the appearance of wrinkles and
that's simply because if you have a whole bunch of
dead skin it can make wrinkles look a lot coarser
scars stretch marks skin tone and dryness
i mean it might make them look a bit better
because you're helping the surface look better
but it's not going to have a really big effect
now scars and stretch marks massage in general can
reduce stretch masks and it can soften up scars
but beyond that i don't think the glove is
doing anything special exfoliation can also
make them look better but again it's not some
sort of magical property of the glove skin tone
exfoliating can get rid of maybe some cells
on the surface but i don't think it's going to
make a massive difference not like the difference
that a proper active like lactic acid could it can
definitely help remove dry flaky skin detox that's
always a red flag for pseudoscience discolorations
that's really vague even tanning will definitely
work fake tan reacts with dead skin so if you
have a lot of dead skin in one area and not
somewhere else you end up with a patchy tan
and so exfoliating before a tan is always a good
idea acne control i guess all exfoliation can help
a bit with acne but that is a pretty big claim
for something that's just a physical exfoliant
so are these gloves too rough on your skin well
i think it really depends one of the issues with
these is that it is really prone to user error
it's very exciting to be rubbing off all of this
dead skin but it turns out that you need dead skin
those 10 to 20 layers on the surface of your skin
are there to protect the living layers of your
skin so if you get rid of too many then you end up
with a really compromised barrier you end up with
stinging and irritation and it takes a while to
build that barrier back up so you need to practice
a bit of self-control with these you can't go too
hard you can't use them too often i think it's
especially dangerous on your face because a lot
of us already use active ingredients that can
pack down our stratum corneum they're already
exfoliating for example and so if you're using
this on top of all those exfoliants then you're
probably getting rid of too much skin that means
that you end up with a compromised barrier and
that means irritation sensitivity your face skin
is also thinner and so you've got less to take
off to start with so after i tried this mitt out
on my face on this half only i noticed there was
a patch of skin here that was a bit dry and flaky
and it also stung a bit when i put sunscreen on it
for about a week afterwards i thought i used
it pretty gently just hard enough to get some
rolls so yeah over exfoliating is really easy
with these mitts i wouldn't recommend using
it on your face if you use any other exfoliating
actives maybe any other irritating actives which
i think is probably everyone who is deep enough
down the skincare rabbit hole to be watching my
channel so for face exfoliation i would probably
recommend something different such as a chemical
exfoliant or maybe a scrub probably not
these definitely not the rougher ones
you also have to be careful when looking
after these you want to let these dry out
properly in between uses the reason is after
you've rubbed off all of this dead skin
dead skin is really good food for bacteria and
when you have moisture and dead skin they grow
and so you end up with lots of bacteria on
these then you rub them back onto your skin
into your skin and you end up with a bacterial
infection the most common one is pseudomonas
folliculitis this is when the bacteria end up
in your hair follicles and it looks a little
bit like tiny red pimples with pus in them
that is bacteria not the kind of gross we want
so is the $70 brand name version worth it i think
it does have a much nicer texture than the cheaper
ones it feels a lot more effective without being
too rough it also feels a lot better constructed
so it should last a bit longer it says it'll
last up to two years according to the packet but
i think the cheaper ones can definitely still do
the job but it might take a few goes to find the
right one you might end up with one that doesn't
really do much you might end up with one that is
a bit too rough and you'll have to use it a
lot more gently i think if i wasn't doing this
for a video i would probably just buy five
cheaper ones and see which one worked best
so i hope you like this slightly disgusting
video you can follow me on instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience and check out my blog
for more about the science behind beauty products
see you next time to nerd out more and i will
try not to talk about disgusting dead skin